كيف يجري التعاطي رسميا وعسكريا من قبل
الجانب الاسرائيلي مع هذه المعطيات
والتطورات
سلمى في الحقيقه يلحظ ان هناك تكتم
اسرائيلي كبير على تفاصيل ما يجري على طول
الحدود مع لبنان باستثناء ما اعترف به
الجيش الاسرائيلي صباح اليوم باصابه
جنديين في قصف لحزب الله اللبناني على
قاعده برانيت العسكريه في الجليل الاعلى
وطبعا حديثه في وقت سابق عن تعرض عدد من
المناطق للقصف قبل قليل فقط وغير بعيد من
هذه المنطقه حيث نقف سمعنا دوي اربعه
انفجارات بعد ذلك كان هناك انذار بوجود
خطر على حول منطقه كريش مونا وبعض البلدات
المجاوره لها وكانت سفرات الانذار ايضا قد
دوت هناك لكن لم يتسنى
لنا الوقوف على حقيقه مصادر تلك
الانفجارات هل هي داخل الحدود اللبنانيه
ام انها حول منطقه كريات شموه قبل ذلك كان
الجيش الاسرائيلي وبالتحديد اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيليه قد اعلنت عن اطلاق صاروخين
مضادين للدروع على منطقه المطله والان فقط
هناك ايضا صوت لانفجار في محيط كريات شموه
التي يبدو ان هناك قصف متبادل بين الطرفين
الجيش الاسرائيلي تحدث حول ما كان او
تعليقا على ما كان حزب الله اللبناني قد
اعلنه في وقت سابق عن
تحقيق ضربات مباشره واستهداف مباشره على
ان على ان كل تلك الصواريخ والقذائف التي
سقطت من الجانب
الاسرائيلي من الجانب اللبناني سقطت في
مناطق مفتوحه ولم تسفر عن وقوع خسائر
ماديه او بشريه وهناك من يقرا طبعا في هذا
تكتم متواصل للجيش الاسرائيلي على تفاصيل
ما يجري في هذه المناطق التي كما نعلم
باتت خاليه من السكان بعد نزوح نحو 70 ال
مستوطن من كل تلك المناطق منذ السابع من
اكتوبر من العام الماضي طبعا باستثناء
ايضا ما كان الجيش الاسرائيلي سلمى قد
اعلنه في وقت سابق على انه تمكن من اسقاط
مسيرتين في منطقه جنوبي الجولان السوري
المحتل الان هذا
الصوت سلمى في الحقيقه يبدو قريب جدا في
ذلك الاتجاه الذي منذ ساعه ونحن نسمع
اصوات للمدفعيه الثقيله وت وتتبعه بعد ذلك
اصوات ل انفجارات قرب الحدود مع لبنان
الجيش الاسرائيلي كان كما سبق وذكرت قد
تحدث عن تنفيذ عدد من الغارات الجويه على
اهداف وبنى تحتيه عسكريه تابعه لحزب الله
خلال الليله الماضيه وقال ايضا بان
المدفعيه الثقيله الاسرائيليه ما زالت
تستهدف تلك البنى التحتيه في محاوله لما
قال انه تحييد اخطار
وتهديدات محتمله على الاراضي المناطق التي
تسيطر عليها طبعا اسرائيل من الجانب
اللبناني طبعا وفق الجيش
الاسرائيلي شكرا جزيلا لك
من الجليل الاعلى امين درغامي وايضا اشكر
مراسلنا من بلده رميش جنوبي لبنان او مدير
مكتبنا مازن ابراهيم شكرا جزيلا لكم